Mr Speaker after 13 years of Tory
failure the average family in Britain
will be poorer than the average family
in Poland by 2030. exactly that's a
shocking State of Affairs
if the tour is limp on in government
we're going to see a generation of young
people learning to say I'll be the same
pet in Polish aren't we
[Applause]
I missed it
Mr Speaker it's clear to everyone that
the biggest impact on households living
standards is the energy crisis that
we're suffering at the moment as a
result of an illegal war in Ukraine and
I just remind The Honorable gentleman
what we are doing to ease people through
that because of our energy price
guarantee right now the government is
paying over half of a typical household
Energy bill saving households right now
a thousand pounds it is one of the most
generous support schemes globally now he
knows he knows future decisions to
support cost of living for the budget
but if he's concerned about the cost of
living what he should do is stop making
inflationary unfunded spending
commitments
and back our plan to halve inflation
[Applause]
the dictionary definition of unfunded
commitments is last year's Kamikaze
budget
as the speaker
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than it was before the pandemic and he
stands there pretending it's all fine
total denial about the damage and
decline that he is presiding over
delivering growth and tackling the cost
of living crisis will mean standing up
to vested interests energy bills energy
bills are going to go up by 900 pounds
in April he knows he's going to have to
act but who's going to pay hard-working
families through higher taxes are more
borrowing or the oil and gas giants
celebrating record profit
to visit Davos recently Perhaps Perhaps
Perhaps Perhaps while he was there
perhaps sir he missed the survey of four
thousand Global CEOs from a hundred
different countries that ranked the
United Kingdom as their number one
European investment okay now if he's
serious if he's serious about getting
the economy growing then he should stand
up to the vested interest in the unions
and back our minimum service
Mr Speaker here's the thing all the CEOs
of business saying there's only one
party with a plan for growth but it's
this party here
there's only one party that broke the
economy and they're sitting there
they're on energy bills it's not as
complicated as he pretends or in a gas
companies are making vast unexpected
profits whilst working people face
misery of higher bills he can boast all
the ice but companies like shell didn't
pay a penny and winful tax last year and
they're still not paying their fair
share now why doesn't he admit his
mistake get rid of the loopholes in his
boxed windfall tax and finally choose
family finances over oil profit
Chancellor
injury tax on Energy company any energy
companies
and energy companies will pay a 75 tax
rate on extraordinary profits comparable
indeed higher than other naughty Nations
now that's what his shadow leveling up
secretary called for recently but I've
got good news of them we did it a year
ago
keep up now I know I know Mr Speaker
they click they claim to support
leveling up but they really do need to
keep up
he introduced a tax on seller they
haven't paid a penny fantastic work
if he was serious about investing in the
future of the country he'd start with
housing a few months ago his back bench
has forced him to scrap house building
targets at the time he stood there and
said it would mean they would build more
homes
well would you believe it a few months
later the home builders Federation say
house building is going to fall to its
lowest level in 75 years now he can
change course on this he can bring back
targets and planning reforms or he
conduct that fight and let a generation
down which is it
[Applause]
hello speaker we've had recordly high
numbers of house bill
years of this government but he talks
about investing for the long term of our
country and if that's important when it
comes to energy security Mr Speaker but
Labor's policy Labor's policy is to
oppose any new oil and gas licenses in
the North Sea it is an absurd policy
that we that would see us pay
while shipping it here with twice the
carbon emissions its typical political
posturing it's bad for the economy it's
bad for all security just like the labor
party
what
because of the noise I don't think the
prime minister is hearing the questions
because I do think it was on Hospital
[Applause]
on house building Mr Speaker that's the
low the low level for 75 years a whole
generation of people desperate to get on
the housing ladder 13 years in power and
all he's got to say to them is it's
somebody else's fault let me deflect no
wonder they're furious with his
government and it's not just bills or
housing farmers are paying over a
thousand pounds a month just to send
their child to Nursery if he scrapped
his non-dom status he could start to
fund better Child Care put money back in
people's pockets and get parents back to
work seems a pretty simple choice to me
so what's he gonna choose wealthy tax
avoiders or hard-working parents
speaker if we want to see what happens
with house bearing under a labor
government just look what's going on in
London Mr Speaker
in fact the facts don't suit his
argument let's just go over them the
wealthiest pay more tax the poorest pay
less tax than under any year of the last
Labor government Mr Speaker
now about his plans he's already spent
he's already spent the money he's claims
he'd raised from that policy on five
different things Mr Speaker it's the
same old labor party always running out
of other people's money
[Applause]